All right guys, so in this lecture, I'm gonna show you how you can identify daily bias easily
So this method was actually taught by ICT himself in one of his videos. I believe it was from sniper series or
Market maker. I'm not quite sure
But yeah, he taught that himself
He said that if you as a beginner if you have if you are having problem with finding daily bias manually
You can use this method. Okay, it's not gonna be as perfect as finding the daily bias manually
But it's gonna work. Okay, and it's better than nothing. So go to the indicators tab here type in moving
average
right and you
Open two moving averages. So the one length is nine
So the length of the first one is nine and the length of the second one is going to be 18
Once you have that
So whenever the moving averages are to the upside right after the cross your bias is bullish
Okay, and whenever the moving averages are to the downside your bias is
bearish simple as that guys non-natural or complicated I
Repeat when the moving averages give across and the price is above the moving averages
Or the moving averages are up to the to the upside like here your bias is gonna be
bullish regardless of what price is doing, okay?
so
This is one way to set foundation, okay, so what I have
Found but back testing if one you once you have a cross right the next two to three days
You can have a bullish bias
But after that you want to look for some sort of liquidy sweep before being bullish again
Okay, so right here you can see we had three consecutive bullish days
So you have to expect some sort of retracement and that retracement
Could be from this very well you gap that was here
So when price comes back to very well you gap you could either be bullish again here or you what you do is you wait for some
Sort of liquidy sweep. So this right here is a liquidy sweep and price candle closes here and your bias is bullish
very very simple guys, okay, um
And right here you can see we have a cross I
Believe right here. So the next day was bearish. Okay, but then what happened was we took out this
High here and you can see the next day was bearish after that
What happened was we took out this high over here and after taking out the high
You can see the next couple of days were bearish
So over here we have a cross again actually cross here, right?
so the next day was bullish as hell and
Remember the volume imbalance video that I thought you guys there is volume imbalance right here and
Also, what happened here was price took out this liquidy
So then the next candle after the close of the next candle your bias is bullish. So see that move
Yep, that's what I'm talking about crossover here
You
Can see kind of close here. Well, the next day I would say it was bullish. Okay, so there's nothing that you can do about it
But then the couple of so the next two days were bearish right here after that
You would have looked for liquidy sweep surprise swept the liquidy here price consolidated for a couple of days
But then you had this, you know up and down up and down
But then you had the next couple of days bearish couple of days
Okay, and after that price swept liquidy boom very simple guys
So let me show you guys here as well. We have a cross boom cross over here boom move move to the upside cross here
bearish cross here bullish, okay, you can see price up liquidy here as well move to the upside
Price swept liquidy here as well. Well, this was you could have been bearish for some days
But then there was this, you know, this autoblock right here price came back here push up
But all you need are moving averages to identify a deli bias guys
It's not gonna be as accurate as finding it manually if you want to learn how to
You know identify a deli bias manually
With a higher accuracy level you can watch my video on YouTube. It's absolutely free or you can learn by ICT himself
So there's another trick that you can use and
That trick is by me actually so you look for ABC patterns, okay?
So this right here you see ABC
When you have a sweep you wait for price to close back and then you when the price comes back to retest as
soon as it retests this line your
Bias could be bearish, but as you can see the moving averages here were bullish
So you got to play
Accordingly if the moving averages are bullish you look for bearish ABCs. Oh, sorry bullish ABCs, okay?
But I'm just showing you if you don't want to use moving averages you can use this technique as well
So let me show you how
Let me go back right here remove the drawings. Let's disable the moving averages
So right here you see we have a BC, right?
So a BC
Then we the price goes above the line and went as soon as you have a retest
Your bias becomes bullish, okay? There was really gap here as well
And you can see how this works
So your bias for the couple of days I was bullish from just for by identifying a daily bias
Okay
You can see right here
We have a
B and then see price comes down retest here and boom
Price
over here ABC
You can see that
Price yes, it did go up here to fill a fill in some imbalance or for every gap on the lower time frame
But then the next couple of days as you can see we're bearish
So this is it for
Identifying daily bias. It's not gonna be as accurate as finding the daily bias manually
But it's better than nothing and it is going to increase or win rate definitely
See you guys in the next video